I'm curious what you think of Ralph Moss's interview regarding soy. Do you still believe that soy
is not beneficial for breast cancer patients after hearing this? He says the weaker estrogen of soy
plugs the hole in the breast cancer cell so that the stronger bodily produced estrogen cannot get into
the breast cell. Just curious if the genistine from soy that's an iso flavoid of soy will help
lower my AFP or do you still advise me against it? So I think what he was looking at with this is
fermented soy and he didn't state that in the interview and I think that was an error. I do think
that soy iso flavoids are estrogen mimics and they should be avoided for people with any
breast cancer even if you don't have ER positive or two positive or PR positive even if you're
triple negative I still think you should still use soy. Now a good fermented soy is completely
different fermented soy actually removes the estrogen from the estrogen beta receptor.
So it is the attachment of the of the bad estrogen of the estrogen beta receptor that
caused that blocks apoptosis. It's not about estrogen getting into the cell at all so
his statement about that is not correct physiology. I think he's a great guy. I've interviewed him on my
podcast before and but I don't think that's correct.